[Musique]
moi je suis le produit de téléphone pour
savoir si ton mec va sur des sites un
peu olé olé évidemment ils vont tous
supprimer les historiques mais qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire vous voyez dans le
temps d'écran les amis quand on écran il
te classe les applis il te met les sites
que ta fréquenté et là il nettoie pas le
si c'est vrai et oui je suis un
psychopathe je suis le mec de you alors
j'ai toutes les infos non mais je te
jure
Djoko on n'arrive pas à le lâcher on
s'aime beaucoup trop il y a une amitié
qu'elle a désormais
je sais pas comment dire mais il est
malade lui il est malade il est malade
j'ai dit plus rien ça y est qu'est-ce
que tu connais au micro toi depuis quand
tu es un Gesson
alors ça va vous
Michel Sardou c'est l'école je sais pas
j'ai fait des années de radio
[Musique]
mais le secret du flan parisien c'est
d'avoir une crème pâtissière qui soit
des cuit avec de la crème fraîche je
m'explique
à la fin on rajoute du beurre et et de
la crème fraîche épaisse
et là
je vais te dire on peut te sortir les
plus grandes pâtisseries les plus belles
sculptures de sucre le flan is the best
[Rires]
[Musique]